we begin with breaking news out of the
afghan capital of kabul the vice
president has survived what appears to
have been
an assassination attempt a spokesman for
amulo saleh says he's
unharmed two other people were killed
when saleh's convoy was
attacked let's get more details on this
now and speak to nasir raheen he's a
journalist in kabul
nasir so what more can you tell us about
this attack on the vice president's
convoy
yes an explosion targeted the conveyor
of first vice president abdullah saleh
in kabul
as the spokesman says mr sally has
survived bombing but
three of his men have been wounded the
afghan ministry of public health says
that the explosion killed
these two people and wanted more than a
dozen
health officials said that women and
children among those wanted
the explosion comes at the moment that
first vice president was going to his
office
uh nasir and who could have been behind
this attack and is anyone likely
to claim responsibility
so far no militant group has claimed
responsibility for the best bombing
and um the taliban and the afghan
government have been talking peace
and they still have not managed to stop
peace talks
so no militant group has so proclaimed
responsibility for this bombing
yeah and this isn't the first time that
umbrella saleh has survived
an assassination attempt why has he
become such a target do you think
well first vice president uh was a
former uh head of nda's intelligence
agency
and he also survived an early attack
last year
uh which where his office was targeted
by militants and
more than a dozen people were killed or
wanted in that attack
and the afghan ministry of police says
that
two people have been killed and milled
and it doesn't want it and no militant
grief has so
far claimed responsibility for that
bombing uh nasir you mentioned
the peace process a little earlier we
know that a taliban delegation
recently returned to doha for more talks
as part of that u.s taliban peace deal
how was this latest attack
on the vice president's life likely to
affect those talks do you think
well the other first uh latest uh
remarks offers vice president
saleh was that that he said that the
afghans are not going to
deal on their values but uh they will
definitely start peace talks but they
will never
make deals on their values and and we
will not compromise on
very important things that uh of that
people have
but uh though uh official has not
said anything about it but the talks
were expected to start uh
in coming days again uh the afghan
minister of
uh peace says that the afghan delegation
will soon depart for qatar for the
sort of peace talks the taliban
spokesman has said that more than 80
prisoners are australian the afghan
prisoners
and the national security council says
that
they are not holding any talent prisoner
and they have released all the taliban
prisoners
according to the list they have been
given by the taliban
more than uh more than six uh taliban
prisoners who were
really dangerous and our day they were
transferred yesterday to doha qatar and
the
popular still facing some problems
because
both sides are making excuses in this
regard
okay nasir rahim thank you very much
indeed for talking to us thank you
nasser
thank you